you're coming through loud and clear okay I guess we're getting 20 mics
1,3, what mics do we need you wanted Charles to move now why are you bye how are you
fine good yeah we tried to go through this you know your debrief last night
the printed one you know there's all the stuff that you guys did on tape
your tech TV to get those sort of we try and not repeat you know only improvise
stuff and so we try to come up too much time to do that but I hope we got
most of that stuff and if you if you think we're hitting some area that you
think you know as a conflict with that well yeah tell us all righty
changer around and some of the things now there were some things that you guys
said yesterday well when I was in the project you briefly that probably bear on
some of these two
all right
I'm going to get in for somebody.
Yeah, I need to swim in the raffle.
I'm going to do it right here.
I don't know if you have any of them.
I don't really do.
We don't have them.
We've got some stuff right now.
I'll fix your day with a lot better than one hand.
This was...
One, two, two.
Yeah.
Great.
Just how about that?
There's a lot more on the door.
There you go.
I've got some things to do.
There's an eye on the door.
There's a lot of things to do.
There's a person to do.
I'm going to do.
Yeah.
I'm going to do a lot of things to do.
That's going to be hard to do.
I'm going to watch the action.
I'm going to do a lot of things to do.
I'll hear what you do.
Okay.
The show's on your...
What kind of format do you have in mind today?
Okay.
Questions and answers?
Yeah.
Questions and answers.
I guess we ought to, for the tape, identify this Dr. Berry and for the medical debriefing
and I'll try and ask most of the questions if people have some here.
We'll try and hand them in that way if they're not.
Will you identify yourself?
And I think they can identify you guys' voices pretty well already on the tape.
So there shouldn't be any problem with the tape thing.
Can I grab a peek at those pipes?
They're not loud enough?
It's not coming.
It's a little down.
Mr. Berry, where is he?
I'll take cover.
Probably outside I guess.
Can you get him to turn him up some?
Well.
We can yell for a while here for the help, but then we can get him to turn him up some.
You just speak up loud.
One, two, three, four, five, five, four, three, two, one.
Please come down low.
Is that what it's coming from there?
I think it's coming.
Not prequel to somebody in here.
Hi, Mr. Berry.
I think I've come.
Go ahead again.
One, two, three, four, five, five, four, three, two, one.
Test down.
That's the only way better to speed down.
Hi.
I think the knob's rolling on this one.
More of you reach the log and clear it back there.
Well, it's not coming in there though.
They're not getting it in there.
We can hear them.
They have a great, but they're not hearing us very well.
They're hearing both of you.
We'll find it back there.
They want that light turn there.
Yes, it's the inside.
The inside.
The speaker and after Mike.
Okay.
I said it on the little setting in here instead of the max.
The max.
They have the vice versa.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Hey, that's a lot better.
Okay.
It's labeled wrong.
They're just screwed up.
They're still not.
Yeah.
We can hear you loud and clear now.
It's great.
Okay.
Good show.
I'm going to start a little bit out of order here, but one of the things that sort of pervades
it all is medical requirements.
And in the section 27, you had some comments about the medical requirements.
And I thought we ought to, we ought to just give one question with you.
In explaining a medical requirements, we have one opportunity to do that with, with
Deek, of course, at the time that we're trying to get the document, the medical requirements
document published.
The second, the only opportunity we really get to go over that with you was at the,
the 38D brief, 38 briefing prior to the flight.
Did you guys feel that you had an understanding of what the requirements were because when
I read this, it sounds like you did not.
Is that true?
I read the forms, Chuck, and understood in general, what, what are you after at least the,
the number of sessions we had?
I think it's a question of degree.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, one of the things we tried is a very valid thing like, thank you.
Alice comments about, you know, you should substantiate the requirements.
No question about that.
They should be clear.
They should be clear to you.
In the sense that you want to know that what you are doing is,
is worthwhile to the stuff issues.
And it isn't, it isn't wasted somewhere down the line.
Somebody's just doing it for fun.
Yeah.
And we try, that's something we try to iron out pretty hard in our own house.
And one of the things I'd like to do is if we run, if you guys end up at the,
sometime before the end of the point of the quarantine period here and
ask them time, we got to have that data together by then and then prior to the
time that we're going to get me out if you've got an hour or
sometime we might be able to go over with you and show you.
Here's, here's what we saw with you and with the lab data in the whole
bit and say, because, you know, it's very hard to get back together again after
you get out of here to do that sort of thing.
Everybody says they'd like to know what happened to them.
We could do that to you and hear and tell you that, and hear the samples
that we're used to do that.
So you have some idea understanding about how to end.
Would that be worthwhile to you?
Yeah.
The comment was made not from a point of view a specific complaint about our
flight, but just continuing understanding between the two
directors.
We agreed ahead John because it's a kind of thing.
Well, just like a lot of scientific experiments, unless the crew understands the
reasons and agrees with it, the other thing isn't going to be a successful
experiment.
Amen.
So it wasn't the comment.
It wasn't made from a point of criticizing anything specifically about our
protocol at all, just to reiterate what, you know, everybody out of
know who doesn't know who's thinking about it.
Yeah.
Good.
And I think John also, probably the last few weeks before
flight is not the time to try to break the crew on the medical
requirements.
At that time, we're thought you're quite a bit on other things.
And perhaps it needs to come earlier than that.
Erin, that's a good, nothing at the point.
I think each one of us is concerned with ourselves medically or the medical
effects, the physiology of flight, et cetera, et cetera.
But the last few weeks, you just can't get yourself cranked up to
really think about those things.
Except for the things that are going to happen to you, you
can be mentally prepared for it.
Right.
I think I may have precipitated that comment.
At least when we got that area and started that, about, and I
guess it really wasn't a complaint, Chuck, as much as just a
statement that it's a drag, you know, going through collecting
urine for 24 hours and so forth.
Right.
And, you know, I just wanted to toss it in and just share hope
that it's worthwhile.
And I think it would be instant to sit down and see how you,
what you're really doing with all that.
Good.
I think that's really needed because we're trying to do that
right now with this kind of increase to tell you what we really
know about what happens to man, what we know from the Russian side
of the thing is to what's happened on even there longer when
put the thing together and say, here's what, here's what we don't
know, and why we need to know.
Well, I think we understood, or I understood your need to work
out the total body water, but the actual mechanics of how that
fit into the 24 hour urine collection six times and all the blood
drawing and how that all fit into the picture, the theoretical
picture you write.
Waiting for us.
I never understood that.
Very good.
Okay.
Very nice.
You know, I think I might stand all these things.
Why don't you, why don't we make a specific recommendation
because why don't you know, all the flakers have a training
plan, which is set up about the time of the flakers
are busy.
And includes all kinds of things and some leaders and scientific
reasons or anything else.
And why is, why wouldn't the best way to do it, actually,
this can do all the time, more medical briefings early in the training
program?
Because I think if you all, kind of rest with you all feel
at the experiments worthwhile doing, you want to get your protocol
settled early in the game.
So you have all the equipment in the way we need.
Amen.
We're ready.
Yes.
Right.
We'll be a satisfactory test.
So I would suggest that maybe sometime we'll be scheduled
in the crew training program early in the game.
Yeah.
And I should play because one of those things you've got to check
off, like systems of briefings and everything else.
And I should think that briefing should consist of a bit of
the theoretical thing you're trying to do, followed by the
mechanics.
What that means, that's right.
The mechanics of how you go about doing it, the number of
punctures and where you're going to do it, and how many
you're inside those sorts of things.
Great.
Just so you guys understand.
OK.
We'll do.
Great.
That's great.
We'll go back and pick up one in on the exercise area.
You mentioned this in the debrief and you mentioned it again in the
yesterday.
But can you give me some idea?
Now you said you missed as I remember the debriefing
statements here.
You commented that you missed one day on the way out and one day
on the way back.
And can you say what you did in time, what the exercise
is consistent of what you did roughly in time.
I know you won't know the minute or the second or anything, but
as roughly as you can.
And then, if you have any idea that you try and judge what you
did as far as did you try and get a heart rate increase or did
you try and judge your exercise level in any way.
And this is particularly important for us in trying to
separate out the effects that are different between the two
and the surface versus stew who is in the spacecraft
all the time.
So we want to keep that and we want to get that straight
if we can.
Could you just sort of brief the exercise as to the way you did
and maybe each of you have to do it because you probably
did it differently?
Well, what we were shooting for was about a ten minute
period per day.
Exclusive about the two days of lunar service activity for
the two of us and stew was going to try to get about ten
ten minute period per day for including those days.
The method of exercise during the ten minute period was
use this extra gym device which we have.
And to operate that in such a fashion that the old,
the couple big four ways to start out with it,
where your legs are going to feed in two lobes in your hands
controlling the friction device.
From a cross position to a full stretch out.
And I do that several times.
Then hold the effects loops and use the legs and the movement
below and then hold the effects loop with the toes
and use the biceps on the movement below.
That's the general pattern that we tried to follow.
But we didn't make all those time rates.
We missed the first day out because of what we didn't have
us getting the first day out of here.
Well, it was in the flight plane, but I don't think anybody
is going to exercise the first day anyway.
In fact, it should never have been in the flight
plane to exercise the first day.
Pretty hard to get that in the first day,
but I don't think it's the problem with the docking probe,
so that it was behind.
We don't really need it in that first day anyway,
but you don't really need it in that first day.
Well, in retrospect, I think that it would probably
believe you in some of the sore back muscles that first
day could go ahead and get it in my case.
It was kind of like one of those things where they said,
OK, you want to exercise?
You put in the flight plane, and I said, yeah,
we've got to have in the flight plane.
What we're going to do is we're going to put it,
I said, put it in before lunch every day before the movement.
And that's how I get in there.
OK.
Did you say the x-ray jam, or is it the x-ray genie?
Or jam?
X-ray jam is a trade name.
Yeah.
We're both similar device.
It's the same thing.
It's the friction one.
Yeah, OK.
Yeah.
OK.
And so 10 minutes a day is what you have program for the thing,
and did you have any idea?
Did you feel it?
You really got a fair amount.
Did you get up any increase in breathing rate or high rate
that you were aware of when you did it?
Yeah, what did you do it quantitatively?
But some of you, yeah.
I always tried to stop short of cracking a sweat.
It's just not desirable to get all sweating in the spacecraft.
And I felt like I was pulling it somewhere around 10 to 15 minutes.
So I could feel a heart rate going up,
and the breathing going up.
But I would never do it to the point of sweat.
And it's not a vigorous exercise.
It's more of a tension exercise.
I put enough load on it to where it was up.
A hard pull with a slow pull.
Right.
He's due.
You're just going about that same way then for the whole time
when you were a little bit.
I've got to just summarize exercise.
In my case, I probably didn't exercise as much in retrospect
as I would have.
So I would do it again.
For very sincere reasons.
One is, you know, you don't feel a need for the exercise.
You've got to say, well, I'm going to go do this.
And there were a couple of times if we got out the,
you know, it says exercise periods.
So we got out the exercise or an allinated habitat.
It'd not be doing something.
I'd say, well, I'll put it over here and I'll get to it in a minute.
And then I don't want occasion several hours later I find
got around to getting to getting it and doing some exercise on it.
I'd say probably five to ten minutes was the length of time.
I would strain pretty hard.
I didn't work up a sweat.
But you know, you use this thing.
You can use it about any way you want.
You can drag them through the ropes or it's really designed
to where you hold and do a nice and metric first.
And then go right from nice and metric into the isotonic
and you get the whole smear.
So I'd hold the whole pressure on the thing and strain against it.
And, you know, you can strain as little or as hard as you want,
but strain reasonably hard and then relax the tension and pull it up.
But I'm trying to think, I'm sure that I missed one exercise period
on the way out completely that Aleneid got in.
I didn't know exercise at all in the New Norweg.
I was thinking of the extra gym was never even crossed my mind for those two days.
And then in preparation for entry, I said,
I'm really going to hit that on the way home.
So I would say out I've barely got in the one exercise a day
that we did on the way home.
So I would say overall I'm sure I didn't hit the extra gym as much as I probably should have.
Okay.
I don't know how, from my point of view,
and in case like this, we're trying to correlate the relationship with the exercise at that night,
if it's happening.
And it's been a fit, so I would like there, I would expect to be on a surface degree,
which is over 30 hours.
I just think the workload, the basic workload there alone is, and that's a different game.
But that exercise thing down at the noise level,
and it's got a mutation down at the noise level as far as the two of other things are.
I think that's probably very right now, and I think that the one I know is,
you know, was still trying to make up for it in some way with exercise in the space sprint,
because he obviously, I mean, there's no way he could make up for what you were doing on the research.
He's trying to, but he had a real busy flight point.
Yeah.
I don't think he could do it.
And this is what I wanted to find out was he was he trying to do a lot more or something during that time.
No, I wasn't.
I think that'd be a difficult thing to try to do, really.
I don't know.
You're going to maybe with the longer period in lunar orbit,
CMP may not be quite as busy, or maybe I suspect he probably will be.
I think it's going to be difficult to get in my checkers out of there.
But no, I was going to agree with you.
Yeah.
Obviously, it's too, it's too, it's very,
it's just where we're on the spacecraft.
And for example, the B23 is going to a lot of time.
That was the kind of, this is the kind of thing I'm talking about.
But if you're going to get the individuals to try to exercise and respond to exercise,
then you're going to have to get to a really explained benefits.
The crew was in all of them.
Right.
It's a really individual thing.
That's right.
And we haven't tried to set any numbers of times that you do anything like that.
And so we need to really carefully look at that as an area.
Okay.
And one that came up yesterday when you guys were talking about
Myrtle reminded me of the problems that you had in right with the urine.
Kinking of the urine hose and so forth.
How much time did you make a conscious effort in your own particular case?
Because this important trying to chase down your status post right here.
The time that you had the insulin urine device on, did you have it?
Me.
Well, it wasn't my hose.
It was kink.
Right.
It was out.
Yeah.
It was twice out.
Probably all the time.
All the time.
Oh yeah.
We had it on.
I guess we'll have to look back on the track script.
It looked like we were the flight plane to know when we took it off the first time.
We all understood it at the same time.
Which was about six hours, seven hours into the flight.
All right.
Somewhere in there.
And we put the UCTA zone of PDI morning.
And we took them off only when we got back to the spacecraft after talking.
And it was all for those who curious.
And I've never experienced any discomfort.
I've never had any problems whatsoever.
That was better.
We discussed pre-flight.
No symptoms.
No, of any short.
Great.
Well, it looks like we didn't have it had any end.
You did.
Well, how did you feel that?
I don't know if we might just get out of wait.
On fluid intake, it sounds like you all thought the water was great.
And so you were drinking well.
Were you trying to force fluid?
Were you trying to consciously force fluid?
Yeah.
I think you would have.
In my case, I mean, yeah.
I tried to drink.
Take the drink out of the water gun about every time I went by it.
I did find that I preferred the juices to water.
And surprisingly enough, as much as I did not care for the juices,
pre-flight, particularly, I didn't pray or anything.
We were drinking a couple of juices per meal, a large portion of the time I was.
And in addition, taking the shot from the water gun about every time I go by it.
I forced myself to drink the water, not that it tasted bad or anything,
but just to keep the fluid intake up.
And so I would drink water.
Like it says, every time you pass the water gun, you say,
well, I think I'll try some of that.
And one person would take a drink of water and pass it around and would put it back up.
Is there any sense though, you still didn't be reading?
You thought you drank about half of me juices as they did.
I said, it's probably good average.
No, I'd say third less.
Yeah, I'd been juices.
Yeah, you drank two juices.
Yeah, I drank two occasionally.
Towards the end, I was drinking two more than I was.
Because a lot of times you drank a cocoa and a juice and I'd bypass the cocoa.
And I just drank a juice.
So I'd say probably, and this is a wag, but I'd say third less juice than they did.
Well, I think I'd kind of decided I was going to try and do everything I could to end up.
And it's been chambers like good at the end of the machine, which included,
keeping the fluid intake and the fluid intake up as well as the exercise.
And this journey will be tried to do.
You did a great moment.
We had to try to get two juices per meal most of the time.
Okay, there was a question here about it for you today.
Did you eat more?
Do you feel why they were with you?
I was with you in the spacecraft.
And when you were alone, eat and drink better.
I saw on your food thing.
Well, I'd say, excuse me, go ahead.
I saw on your food comments there that you had difficulty.
You know, the food preparation thing you'd have preferred if you didn't have some,
kind of things you could have opened quickly and gotten to when you were alone that way.
And I can surely understand that.
I think it's somewhere I'm looking at.
Well, that's the way I did eat.
Because we had them there.
I guess it didn't come out right because that's the way I did eat in the normal.
I would say the answer to your question would be, yes,
that I ate more when they were in there.
But the idea of people being together is nothing in that.
It's a time factor.
During the coast phase, you have more time to worry about eating.
During that lunar orbit phase, I didn't have any time at all.
And any extra time, and particularly with the trouble shooting the hike on and so forth.
So I didn't have an inclination.
I wanted to go to the trouble of trying to mix up a meal or such.
And I didn't much like that going all that trouble anyway.
So I opened up a can that chicken salad, I think it was.
And I had that for breakfast and a wet pack.
And that's the type of food that you can really get to in a hurry and eat.
Right.
So I wouldn't say overall that that probably ended up eating too much less,
but it was a little different rather than sitting down and mixing up a recalibratable pack and so forth.
So the total amount you don't think was any different because you're there,
but it was just different kinds of food there.
It may have been a little less, but do you personally feel that you know the weight loss is involved here?
You know, you've got one pound each here and you've got a ten pound one.
And I heard you're comment about the scale yesterday too.
But do you have any personal reason why you think there's that much difference in the weight loss?
I mean, is there anything that you know that you personally try to account for it other than that food intake,
water intake, or anything of that sort?
No, I'm not sure that there's anything magic about zero G or the fly.
I would suspect I'd probably lost several pounds if I'd eaten that same menu and sat right here.
I probably think that I was serving pounds overweight when I went into the flight.
It's a matter of fact, you know, I'm not a big eater.
And during most of the time you come up on training, I drink a can of sego and a can of VH use for breakfast.
And then I'd eat a sandwich for lunch and you know maybe drink two or three cans of beer.
And eat a sandwich and eat it. And you know, I eat three.
You know, you know, I can go for days on a menu like that.
And I don't know how many calories all that adds up to you.
But you know, it's not really a high calorie diet.
And I would say that that pretty much was my diet for three months prior to going into quarantine was just about what I stated there.
And then when we got into quarantine or then I started eating more for breakfast and eating a bigger meal in the evening.
And so I think I probably was through four pounds heavy going into the flight.
And so I think the weight loss may be overplayed a little bit because I think I had a few extra pounds.
And plus I don't think that we picked the right way up on the rolling scales.
But that's needed here and there, you know what?
Well, we can probably show you something about that from when we get your lab mature up all together.
I think we'd be able to give you a better handle on that as to whether, you know, it really was something that had to do with the zero G state or not.
We hope we'll be able to do that.
So we'll try.
I like it as the other general comment, which I think reflects a consensus here with three of us there.
There was back to the food in general, the type of food, the method by which it was packaged and so on.
And the degree to which we liked it just like it was primarily a function of the level of activity in the flight plane.
But the business is going into the pantry and taking time to select foods and drinks and so on.
During the quiet periods of course, things like black spoon packages are good.
The level of activity is not too high, but certainly at the level of activity is high.
The web packs and the cans, and that's what I want to take time to food with.
I think this is a general comment that really reflects our consensus.
It was a time consuming part of the day to prepare meals, get them all, get them out of the food box,
get them all laid out, cut all the tops off, get all the water into them, get them the sides, and go buddy.
Get the pill back in there.
You know, it's an effort.
You're right.
And it's a lot easier to open up a can and a web pack.
And then you think it's a lot of trouble.
It mix up the juice.
And that way you got your meal and you're through and you're on your way.
Right.
Okay.
The cooking problem, you quote, is still a promise in, which has been fairly, fairly common, I guess.
Yeah.
I think it'd be a playtime.
You don't watch, buddy.
Yeah.
It's a better package.
It's a very close valor.
Yeah.
It gets rid of that type.
Very effective.
But I would say in my case, watching these guys eat, you know, they went right down the menu.
And so I've thought, you know, I really, I really should do that.
But I just didn't have any information to eat that amount.
And, you know, even though you're on your own mind, you know, hey, you got to do this,
you know, and you got to keep yourself, you know, just as much as you possibly can.
I just couldn't get around to doing it.
In fact, several times I'd mix the food up.
And then by the time I'd eat a couple of packages, you know, I just couldn't get to the,
to the third package.
And so I'd put it back in the pantry.
Well, still one of the things that's going to come out of there is somebody, you know,
reading the, the, the, you know, be breathing.
And so the obvious question comes up, okay, was your loss of it?
Your lack of appetite itself?
Was it just plain lack of appetite?
Did you really have any, any discomfort in your, as far as that guy was concerned at all?
Anything that, that you felt was pathological in your loss of appetite?
Due to the environment or anything?
No.
I don't think there's anything at that.
Like I say, I think it, it, it boils down to a lot of just too much food.
You know, you, you've done a lot of one of those meals.
And there's just too much there to eat.
Were any of you ever thirsty in the fry?
Did you were dry thirsty?
Yeah.
You were dry quite a bit, you know, you'd have a sensation of dryness and you'd want,
and water, you know, juice would make you.
Once in a while.
Yeah.
Did you, while we're at it when we might just wipe out the water?
Did you guys drink the water in your suits?
The EVA?
I didn't drink all of this.
I just drank them out through.
On the first one, I don't know how much it went.
I drank.
I thought I'd get the bag.
But apparently, the walls of the bag got around the drink tube,
and I didn't get it all out because it drained down around my neck during the sleep period.
I had a leaky one also when I took out.
What do you use?
Okay.
Did you fill them up again and when you went out secondly?
And you drank about, you think you drank about 30 years both times?
I say, yeah, I didn't really stop drinking.
Yeah.
And I drank all the money in the second EVA.
And I can't remember whether I drank it all or not.
If I didn't, there may be some still in it.
Okay.
All right.
Hey, one other comment I'll go around there eating before I forget it.
We ran completely out of these bite-sized packages, you know.
And to me, that was the best thing we had.
These little turkey sandwiches, cheese sandwiches, and that sort of thing.
Because that was a no sweat operation.
You just clip that off and a can of juice, and you could go at it.
So I really liked those.
And I eat all those generally that I could get my hands on.
And we ran out of those.
Well, we ran out of both everything else, too.
Just about it.
Yeah.
No, not really.
I had all kinds of food.
But if I may make a comment, just do it in mind.
Well, I guess I would be reading that.
This flight plan is really something I need to work on, you know, for the flight.
It's a busy flight plan.
It's a full one.
And it was my impression that he was more interested in being sure that the flight plan
was done properly than that.
The needy.
Oh, yeah.
I think that affected the security degree, which again gets back to level of activity
versus the...
If you guys can get a little... for example, those pig bags, get a little diaphragm on the end.
Just stick over a needle and pump the water in that way.
And shake it up, pull the plug out, and break it out of the same needle.
It would be a lot easier for those drinks.
I mean, for the juicers and things, you mean, all cutting.
Yeah, so you don't end up having to sort of feel you've got to drink the whole damn thing once you get it done.
You see that drink bag and you've got a little barrel of the thing that's all sucked in,
and plastic is all pulled down.
Right.
It's exactly right.
First of all, you can't get it all the time.
When you get it all done, you've got to go cut the other end.
And I was just thinking maybe it might be an easy way to put a diaphragm on the other
or if you could stick over a hypodermic type of thing, get the water in that way.
Might be a little bit quite the way to do it.
Okay, I think you did it.
Make it easier to help increase the consumption.
Right.
Particularly during busy time periods.
Okay.
But clip, we get you...
I'm just going to log just really how I...
And we might have you describe as well as you can.
The things that you did with your...
with your biostromatation harness is when...
because it's very hard for us to be sure exactly what happened.
We don't have that stuff back yet.
We're going to say we've got a guide about the plan to troubleshoot it.
And as I...
The thing that happened with yours out is from our...
What actions?
Not the words.
All right.
You want the action stuff?
The action is not the word.
Yeah.
Okay.
What you said in some of the words too.
But what...
From our point of view, what happened with your particular harness is...
Everything was fine when everybody left the MS-O-B.
Okay.
When you got into the spacecraft, right after you got...
Apparently when you were getting cinched down somehow,
because we had about three minutes or so after you were in the...
in the couch of good data on you.
Then we began to get erratic.
It began to wind.
It baseline began to wind all over the place.
That continued to get worse and worse and pretty soon it was going just full scale,
which was totally unreadable.
So the question was, okay, it was a question about hatch closure at that point in time.
We decided, right then, I said, well,
we're going to go without that because I'm sure it's a sensor.
The only way to get at it anyway, if you...
We asked you then to try and press on those things.
If that will do it, if that wouldn't recede it,
then the first opportunity would be when we got you actually in flight.
Now, we don't know why, but it came back.
It was gone still.
When you went over Australia, as you came back up on the stage magically,
there we had data.
And we went back to the MS-O-B from the firing room to catch that pass.
And there you were a wet that was beautiful just as if nothing had ever happened.
And you hadn't done a damn thing because then we asked them, you know,
now, as we understand when you looked at that sensor then,
that you did have some material that had leaked out from underneath it,
and we understand that you replaced that sensor.
You cleaned up and replaced that sensor, is that right?
We did replace the sensor now.
Okay, just to clage it off, refill it, put a new sticky back on it,
and put it back on.
Yeah, okay.
That was the second day of the flight.
Yeah, the second day.
Right.
Yeah.
That was the first time that we really did.
And that we asked you to do that then because we thought we'd get it out of the way
before you got into it.
Okay.
And then you had another.
It also changed the adapter.
You see that we achieved the adapter because at one time on the flight,
they said my car wasn't very good.
Yeah, you're calm with terrible.
Right.
Yeah, it's very adapter.
And so it changed that.
I don't know.
That was pretty early too.
I think it was the first day.
Right.
Yeah, I think it was the first day.
Just do the L.
That was the Lord.
Okay.
Are you ready to do the launch problem?
No.
Because of course not.
And we had it.
We had a respiration.
You can see respiration.
But we didn't have that.
That's good.
Yeah.
But we didn't have anything to do.
Very reassuring today.
That's right.
Good.
You can correlate the reappearance of your EKG signal.
Then he had plain like to be that you might have been doing it.
I sure can.
I just multiply about that.
You were I tried to press it through the suit or anything.
It happened.
It can't be anything to the suit.
Well, you were free then.
No, you had your helmet gloves off.
It was what are in every minute's GTO.
I know that means any bells.
How was it buzzer off at that time?
We were moving around with the most insertion checklist.
And the sort of movement in the couch.
But I did get some things.
Well, no, I'm still at some stuff.
It's probably, it just got to be that you were probably just,
it was in the cinching down in the, in the couch that it probably
loosened that edge of that sensor somehow a little bit.
And I don't know why.
Or put a cramp in a lead.
Yeah.
A lot of the conduct with a something else.
Because it sure came back fine after that.
Okay.
In the second time, what else did you have with, with yourself
from your point?
What else did you do to the thing?
Yeah.
The other thing I noticed was about the next of the last day
that the thread coupling between the sensor line, sensor
harness, and the belt.
The little damage goes through the belt.
The on top of the signal condition.
Yeah.
The strip of the threads.
I could get it to hold a little bit.
And apparently the signal was fine.
Then it would slip off.
But it came back beautifully when you tell you.
But then while I considered it at the end, I noticed that
it was loose.
So it was a brand of strip on that.
Wow.
I got a cramp down too hard.
Did you, did you routinely disconnect that connector at
the signal conditioner for sleep or for bowel movements?
It's like for bowel movements and for swabbing out and cleaning out process.
In time, you pulled your clothes off.
You had to change clothes.
From the LCG or use the blue bags, whatever.
We all had to do them.
Okay.
And then you didn't replace anything.
You didn't do it after recede any sensor after that.
That was the only other thing you had was the signal.
The same time I took the sensor off.
Was that a person?
That call was correct because me took it off.
I see the secrets of the electrolyte.
Same with that.
Okay.
How about yours in it?
The only thing that I replaced was that one sensor.
Which one?
And it was, do you want to say the whole sensor?
I don't mean to replace the sensor.
We pulled it off, cleaned it out, refilled it with the electrolyte.
Put it back on.
Just the same.
Just the same out.
Okay.
You did not take the harness out of the kit and replace the hole.
We thought you had done that.
Well, you called and asked for that.
But there wasn't time to do it.
So we took it.
Then you couldn't hear what we said when you guys said that.
We took the chance that the real problem was simply the sensor in the electrolyte.
That's what it was.
That's exactly what it was.
We couldn't affect the worst time in the standpoint of timeline.
Is that right?
Just getting ready to go into the lab, you know.
Everybody's all asking elbows and suits and underwear and gear and books and everything
all over the place.
I was sitting there hand dressed.
I didn't want to go any further.
We got to go on it.
We couldn't get the high bit right up.
You guys can look at it.
Right.
And so it was one of any time left.
So we changed that when I went in and dressed.
Yeah.
Do you know when you came up there?
The data, you gave us about two minutes when the high gain did lock on.
And we got two minutes of data.
And it still showed the loose sensor.
Now, what did you do the second time?
You came up and asked us how the data looked.
And we said it looked poorly.
And we gave you no more in the shooting to change our partners.
I don't recall exactly the sequence of events.
When I called and asked for you to check it, you know, as far as I know we did nothing
after that, except make sure everything was synched down and went ahead and dressed.
Didn't you do something with the fluid in there?
Yeah.
I'd already done it at that point.
I changed the electrolyte when I called and asked you guys to check it.
I did nothing after that, except just make sure everything was secure.
Yeah.
Because you see the first time you called the data was poor.
And that was the basis for the call of change on the whole highest.
Because he said, well, it wasn't that sensor.
And we didn't have time to talk to you because LOS was coming up.
So he said, go ahead and change out the whole thing.
But whatever you did, that subsequently corrected it.
Because he came back beautifully.
So he assumed you had just changed out the whole range.
It was a little hole in the hole.
Yeah.
So you know that you mentioned it, you know, I just can't remember precisely when we
changed it.
But I'm thinking that I've already changed at that point.
Okay.
And it was just the lower stroke.
Here's the lower stroke.
Same as the same as the same as L.
No big change.
It was electrolyte.
Yeah.
And you think you did that before LOS.
He probably did what we were thinking now happened.
Probably took a while for it to see properly.
And then when he came around, it was good.
Well, his state stayed good then.
And we were having trouble with years going in.
You began to get this wandering baseline on years again before the, you know,
after we got into the land.
And so there was a question in our minds about it.
Is there any way we could do it to get that better?
You know, to make that better.
We were trying to find trying to figure some way.
Could you reach around when you were in the suit?
Is there any way you could get at that thing if you took like after the
EVA ended up taking the helmet on?
Could you get down into the suit here?
You really have to have the upper choice of garment.
The upper part of the choice of garment.
Clear the body in order to be able to feel that.
You know what you can definitely tell.
You know, the other guy goes through the back,
except we're around in front.
Then we tried that on the ground to see if you could do that.
That's pretty hard to do.
We know.
The most you can do is press it.
That's a lot of times corny.
That's pretty dangerous too.
Yeah.
You guys are worried.
The hands is okay.
All right.
Forget the EVA.
Just keep pulling with my sensory.
Yeah.
You've got two hours to stop that.
Okay.
Uh,
uh,
did,
did the thing we got from the sleep.
And I,
uh,
which I think is fairly well covered with you.
I mean, you can't do that.
Well,
we, we like you too.
But what we got out of it is that,
oh, you pretty well never really had a,
a solid long sleep period that it was broken.
And it was things like a couple of hours at a time or something.
And I gather that the,
the reasons for that very,
you had some difficulty with,
with,
you know,
wanting,
wanting to feel some pressure in its case.
I know.
And this,
I'll mention this too.
And,
uh,
didn't like the couch.
And,
and then you ended up,
uh,
in the limb,
the thing was being the suits all the time.
And then the tilt,
the limb,
two,
both those things probably had a lot to do with the sleep activity.
Is there anything else that you can,
that you,
that you think you can edit,
you feel that you,
that you were arrested enough to do the task,
even with the sleep that you had.
But I think we're working on reserves.
Yeah.
I did too.
Well,
there were two days that we felt sloppy.
One was the second day out after the excitement of the launch,
you know,
back to the end.
Being,
coming,
activated to the new environment.
So we felt like we weren't really
clinging on to,
uh,
the second day out.
Now,
the day after GEI,
we all apparently slept better after
GEI,
that night,
I guess was probably,
terms of
continuous sleep,
the best night,
the problem is still the next day,
we felt like we were not really organized.
We got things done,
but the little things were not being handled as neatly,
as we would like to see themselves.
He isn't doing two days,
and we felt the little work on top of them.
But I plan.
I think,
Chuck,
I feel that,
that for no longer than we work for nine days,
that you can get along on a fairly small amount of sleep
and just your reserves
and your discipline and everything else
makes you do the job properly.
But in my case,
I felt very strongly
that I was on reserves
that physically I was going downhill
and the,
it was of some concern to me
that I wasn't getting enough sleep.
I knew I wasn't getting enough sleep,
and yet I felt fairly wide awake
and alert on most of the days,
except two days I was talking about.
But sleeping to me was a very insecure experience.
And how do you mean to get you?
Because of this morning,
the morning's something.
I don't think I want to feel like
the best I can say,
feel like you're in a bed.
You know,
wanting to feel some pressure
or to be lying on something.
It was a pleasant thing.
It was a pleasant thing to go to.
I still knew it.
I knew it.
It was really a pleasant experience
to be in zero G
during the daytime,
I thought.
It wasn't quite a pleasant experience at night.
Well, did you feel,
that brings up this thing.
Did you feel,
I gathered from Alice Commons
in particular,
this business up using your legs
and your feet
to try and hang on to something,
which has been described
by other guys too at some length?
Did you have a feeling
that that was the cause
of this muscle business in your back
more than because,
you know,
that's been described
and they never been able
to really put a hand
on the way they felt that they had
this sort of feeling
that if they could just stretch
that real good,
you think it is due to the fact
that you had
were trying to rock on the summer?
Thank you, Jack.
Yeah,
that's why I analyzed it
the first couple of days,
I think we discussed it
in some manufacturing,
so we started exercise
and then deliberately
take time out to relax.
No, you're in sleep room,
but also try to adapt ourselves
to a relaxed state during the awake
periods in the seats
or on the optics
or in the tunnel or something.
And after the second day,
it kind of went away.
Yeah,
that small of the back problem
was gone after a couple of days.
And in fact,
I was kind of surprised
that we'll come up that
first morning
and my back had bothered me
during the night.
And I didn't realize
that Allen Edge
had a back was bothered
them at that time too.
You know,
and I said,
you know,
I really didn't get that much sleep,
but this sounds
crazy as well,
because I can lay
on that big fine
king-sized bed
at the house.
And if I get a lot of sleep,
you know,
if I lay that for,
hours,
the small of my back bothers me.
Sure.
And I said
to these guys,
I said,
hey,
this is crazy.
I didn't sleep that much last night,
but my back feels
just like I'd got about
that hour's sleep.
And they said,
well,
mine does too.
And then we got
to talking about it.
And,
but it was there,
and it was very conscious
to me that first night.
In fact,
I thought probably my back
kept me going
to sleep as much
as the new environment
rather than the zero g
because I was always conscious
of my back bottom.
Did you ever think
about taking an aspirin
or anything to do anything
with that?
Did you?
I'd never take aspirin at all
for them,
for the eighth thing.
I think until the time
we discussed it,
I was convinced
that the reason
I was feeling
bad in the back
was just not urinating
or some damn
longer.
Well,
I wondered if you would
bring that,
I did think that.
And then after we started
discussing it,
I said,
well,
it may not be the problem
but everybody's got it.
Everybody's got it.
And I agree
with how
and it has something to do
with the way you try
to use your feet
to stabilize yourself.
And I found
I believe,
although I couldn't see myself,
I believe that
when I was relaxing
in the spacecraft
and zebra g,
I was in a curved position
and it felt good
and that's all
the show was back
straightened out
or to take the extra
gym and
get some tension
on those back muscles.
You tend
to assume
like a fetal position
and you just totally relax.
Your legs will tend
to float
up and come
up in a sort of
semi-seals
and your hands
would tend
to float out
about like this
and your back
hands to tension.
So it tends
to assume that kind
of a position.
If you just let
all your muscles go,
so you don't have any muscle
workout.
Oh,
I tell you
that one of the good things
for that back too
is just exactly that position.
Just get yourself up
like this.
Sleep a good bit.
I reached down
and grab a hold
of my booties
and I would lay there
like that
with pulling
some pressure
on my legs
and it would
really help
that smaller
your back head.
I felt
both things
either straightened
out
to put some tension
on the back muscles
or as
do says
double on other way.
It'd pull the other way.
How about
when you got back
onto the carrier
down,
you got
into a bed
in the environment?
Did you have any feeling
did you have the feeling
that you were
real heavy?
Did you were thinking
into the bed
did you have that
when you were on a table
or anything on the
x-ray table
or anything.
None of you
experienced that.
How about
weight of clothes?
Did you have a weight
of clothes?
Pants were too heavy
or they were falling
or anything like that
when you first got back.
One
thing I can remember
about laying down
on the bunk was
it was a good
way on your
on your stomach.
You know,
I generally
I don't know which way
I sleep most
back or stomach
but you know
I was having
depression no matter
in what position
you are
in the spacecraft
you're on your back.
And so
I remember
thinking
that the first thing
I laid down
in the bunk was I
stressed out on my back
and I thought
gee I've been in this way
for nine days
I think I'll turn over
so I rolled over
on my stomach
Did any of you have any
dreams at all?
Did you ever dream
in flying at all?
I did
but I couldn't
put a light on my phone
That doesn't matter
yeah I had dream
but you did have dream
activity at least
because I had
served these things
good
Yeah I think
of that heavy
field of
time
I noticed
it was
after we landed
told the spacecraft
we had
strapped
the spacecraft
down the L.E.B. right away
in the first couple of steps
combination
of little rockets
spacecraft
and being
one G.M.
for perhaps
three seconds
no more
than answer
that was my experience
to start a nice
deep deep end
right away
for maybe ten
twelve of those
babies
and I was right
back home
again
to continue
to feel that way
no more
some stories
when you first went
down the L.E.B. was
out
was that all over
was that just heavy
or some
or you just feel heavy
all over
just all over
how about when you
first got
got some G on
reentry
did you have a
sensation
channel
more G
and then you really
ran a stream
over two
two
was I
supposed
to
these two
guys
that
you
I
think
you become
very sensitive
to
like even
even all
in the
spacecraft
you know
uh
well
I
think
it's
well
the
S.P.S.
engine of course
you know
but
it's
certainly
you're
sensitive
I
wasn't
quite as
busy during
the
mission
period
is
they
were
it
felt
me
like
one
held
alone
in
particular
my
one
and
I
feel
very
heavy
and
I
feel
very
sharp
rise
very
sharp
rise
and
hope
but
I
thought
just
use
but
a
worry
getting used to being back, and then one G-bone, and then you're on a shift, too, which isn't moving around.
Just didn't last for any of you for longer than a few minutes really getting out of the house.
I felt like having a goal.
No, neither does.
How about putting your feet in the right place?
Did you feel like when you were walking, that you were walking normally,
that your steps were normally or anything?
You didn't have to worry about where your feet were?
No, I think that up to the point we got in the MQF.
I felt that it took a little care to make sure my foot was going forward.
Was supposed to be going, but it wasn't out of the ordinary.
Really severe anything.
It seemed to be improving very rapidly from a very heavy state for the first 30 to 45 seconds after I got out of the couch.
Two within an hour or so after I was in the MQF, the footing was very sure.
I do remember stumbling once going into the MQF from the helicopter,
and I didn't see things stumble over.
I just stumbled.
You know, I think, hell, you do that right now though.
If you're going to walk out of that door with the television camera on you,
and you're going to walk up to the front steps, you'd be more conscious of your footing.
You'd be more conscious of your footing, whether or not you've been in zero G or not.
Sure, if you're carrying a load, you're going to look very carefully where you're thinking,
you're not going to get knocked down.
Yeah, and you and particularly know that, you know, you've just come back from a flight,
and people are going to be watching how you're walking and all of this stuff.
So, you know, it's in your mind, and, you know, you've got to walk this 30 feet to the MQF,
so you're just naturally here.
You're more conscious of where you're going to put your belt.
Well, I may have psyched myself in the stumbling for that reason,
but nevertheless, I did stumble.
It's better than back than I was.
Did you notice any distortion of your facial features at all?
Did you, when you look at the TV, the M5 TV, as we watched you,
you know, inside the spacecraft, you get the impression that your faces are not like they are now,
that they're much rounder, that that's a thing of seeing the TV.
Is that true?
Is that, did you feel that when you were looking at each other?
No, but I observed it when I saw a picture of us taking from that TV,
and I didn't think anything about it until you mentioned it.
It looks quite round.
You look much different than you do now.
It takes, it's very round.
But you weren't aware of that looking at each other.
You know, how Wayne has made a comment of that in the 12 report that actually
he looked around and everybody looked 20 pounds heavier.
And I remember that.
And I looked at these guys, you know, it looked just as bad then.
I had to remember that comment from Hal Bainter for it.
And I really didn't notice it.
They were the 12 crew, I guess, been the one that was the most impressed with that of anybody.
And they felt even if they had redness of the face for several hours,
and they first continued to orbit.
Well, that's the general failure of all of a sudden.
Yes.
But I mean, just to look at a person and see a space puffed up,
I didn't notice that at all.
Maybe it just lapped about starvation.
But for the first five hours,
I'm too busy to have a face.
Did you have any sensation that in the first 24 hours in flight that you urinated more
than you normally would?
Then you did the rest of the flight time.
I don't know.
That's a hard thing to remember,
but do you have any idea that you didn't know?
When I showed that out at all,
I never used my UCTA.
That first one was a walker.
I know that.
Of course you got a lot of excitement to make it a walker anyway,
so it's hard.
Now, no real one way the other one I didn't see.
Okay.
What's the, can you come in on the work that you did
EVA out on the lunar surface as far as,
is what you felt based versus your ground training.
Do you think it was harder, easier, about the same?
And secondly, as I said in the question,
did you, did either of you feel really physically tired
to the point that you knew that you were really tired during the EVA?
Is even going out and coming.
I felt, of course, it was an order of magnitude easier than one dream training.
Just no comparison at all as we expected it to be.
And as far as, as being tired,
I had already made up my mind that I did not want to sweat
in all the mood, that I was going to keep the water up
and I was going to keep resting enough so that I didn't sweat
for consumables and for fatigue purposes.
So I never really felt tired.
I did feel occasionally that I was approaching the point
where I'd have had more cooling or take a break.
But it wasn't because of a tired feeling.
The desired and programmed and played consumables,
the way we wanted to.
And not, not behind.
So I felt in my mind that I was stopping short of the point of fatigue
as a direct plan of not wanting to use a consumable.
Am I you?
Well, it's kind of hard to equate the pre-flight stuff
with flexor.
First of all, if you're not using L-C-G
and the pre-flight stuff, you know,
the three ones essentially one G.
Yeah.
This is an equipment run, so I don't know.
So it's pretty hard to equate the two.
One of them is to whether it was hard or easier
or even flight around the standpoint of total work-up,
but certainly the same point of ease of mobility
is what his head says.
It's a lot easier to get around.
I think you travel a lot faster and easier
when the service is a general common.
DBA-1 did not feel uncomfortable at any time of all.
DBA-2, I think the fact that it was aware
of the workloads manifested primarily
in a respiration rate, as opposed to any else.
I didn't feel as though the body was going up too much.
The D-body was going up too much.
And it's primarily because of the circulating flow of L-C-G.
And I was not aware of any profuse of his sweating.
Just a little thing to change it,
but I'm sweating.
I'm blushing when you're in my car.
It's when I went to the medium flow on the water.
So I think, of course, you're not really aware of,
but I had increased in heart radio,
but you specifically stopped and measured it some time.
So I think to me that I think it was most obvious
about the increased workload was the respiration rate.
And at times, I think we suggested climbing the steepest grade
of the grade of the cone.
We stopped and did the rest.
And if you also guessed it, I'm right.
But the standpoint of being tied to the degree
where we didn't want to press on after the short rest period,
in the way I feel that at any time,
until after the two days was over,
and we moved back in the commandmentage.
It was really felt like I was behind the power curve,
as far as the total workload was.
Well, we'll try and give you some firm feeling
for what happened with your UVA's.
When we do this later,
you know, we can show you actually what,
you know, you didn't have some times
where you both got our rates that were up in the 150-year year.
And this is why we felt,
and your respiratory rates were very audible.
And we didn't have a respiration trace on you at that time,
as you know.
But you did have very audible respiratory rates,
and it was obvious that you were increasing those.
And now, I think you began to store.
I think the thing is you kept yours on men for a long time.
And then when you did turn up to meet and flow,
you just left it there a short period of time,
and it didn't kick your rate down as much
because you still were maintaining some of that heat in there.
Now, it wasn't enough to make you sweat, apparently.
And then when you started doing that,
and turning it on a little bit longer,
it just settled right back down.
You didn't have any trouble with it at all.
But both of you came down very well.
When you would rest, your rates dropped down.
And that's contrary to what happened on 12
where they didn't drop down when they rested.
And yours did very well.
They just dropped, they'd come right on down
as soon as you stopped doing that activity.
The amount of feeling that you could have been feeling
any recommendation about extending EVAs now
and you feel that it would be possible
with proper consumables, of course,
that you could, that is physically possible to do that.
I sure do.
The thing that bothered me was worrying about consumables.
I'm the knowing that we were getting a higher metabolic load
to higher heart rate, more oxygen consumption,
going out, pulling crater,
and that I was spending more time on
between minimal and intermediate cooling
because we were rushing, deliberately rushing to kind of make up time.
I started worrying about consumables,
and especially in the water in the oxygen.
And I felt that was a limiting factor.
I didn't feel that I was the limiting factor.
Just the oxygen in the water I was consuming were bothering me.
Well, we tried to give you the word that you were pretty fat up
and soon was really at the time.
We thought you were trying to save consumables,
but we were.
And understandably so.
So we wanted you to know that you had enough.
You could go to medium flow,
when I really get yourself in a hole,
what's the thing we want you to know?
And after you did, I spent some certainly more time on
between minimal and intermediate.
Yeah.
I'll sort it out.
You both did.
It's good.
I don't think I think the comment is wrong.
We'd like the comment about how to work on respect
to the two-day period.
I wouldn't want to see a crew ever planned to do any more
than we did most of the day.
I mean, for us I could, sir,
and that's a bunch of heavy workloads anybody ought to do.
And, sir, if you're going to go off along with crazy VBA,
you got a lot longer, great to rest.
And make sure somehow that they get to rest.
Yeah.
Well, tell me.
If you had, you know, in the in the limb,
I gather one of the things that you'd think would help,
of course, would be getting out of suit.
That certainly would help if you could get out of suit
in a way.
No question about that.
If you had something for a sleep,
would you take it?
Would you guys have taken the limb?
If you had had some for sleep information.
I don't think so.
I don't think I don't want to analyze it.
I don't take that kind of medication here in the crowd.
It's an individual thing.
It's quite obvious way.
And, you know, it just depends on what it is.
I do think it's as closely,
especially if you can't believe
the ground environment is probably the way everybody would.
Right.
So, if you have people that do that in the ground,
you can help them.
I prefer to see us using more natural means of getting a sleep
as opposed to the northern person.
You might ask something to sleep on, please.
Thank you.
Back to that again.
I think the sixth and big thing for us,
that's fantastic.
Yeah.
Thank you for coming up.
Good role around it.
Thank you, David.
You could roll around on the hammock,
and then back around with the back of the neck.
Yeah.
There was one thing,
Chuck, about the fatigue.
The only thing that I had felt
fatigue, any muscle that I felt
fatigue was a darn hand muscle
in the right hand.
Because of the sick part of that blood.
Because you were fighting that blood.
Yeah.
And working the core tubes,
getting unscrewing the core tubes.
What if I couldn't get by myself
getting the caps off of them?
I was very fatiguing,
and that arm gave out.
How about when you're carrying a barbell out there
and you're getting this thing?
You said you had to do it well.
Well, that was tiring.
It just because it's so cumbersome
and it was flopping all around.
But I eventually put it across my arms
like that,
and it just decided from the work load
of carrying it out,
it was no problem.
It was heavy.
Was the weight didn't seem different
because you commented at the time
and it sounded,
and it looked like you were having trouble getting
out there when I think it was the weight of it?
Or was it just the fact that it was vibrating
and it was starting to fit?
It was mostly the vibration
of just flopping that.
I think that it was heavier
than I expected from the 1-6G mock-up.
But we had never carried it that far
in training,
and I think we made that recommendation
at least once the guys on a carry-in.
No way.
The whole weight.
But it was primarily the flopping
of those weights on the head
that were giving trouble.
Okay.
Let's get the eye candidate
on this bowel movement thing
that the preps and so forth.
You had a good comment
in there that went fairly well.
You all did the same thing.
We knew pre-flight anyway.
How did it work out though?
And the thing that you remember
can you just tell us each
each one how you went?
I'd get the red one almost
at the end without having one
according to a comment.
Where did you go?
When did you get it?
I went to the morning of the eighth day
to the morning of the eighth day
was the first one.
And that's the only one I assumed.
I didn't plan that way.
What I wanted to do was
to have one bowel movement
before we went to the surface.
So that would take care
of that period of time
and I went around
with a bag on my family
for about 12 hours.
Hopefully I can do something
and never do it.
And at one point
I even wished
that if we had a laxative
important to help me do that.
I'm not sure what.
It's a good idea or not,
but it sure seemed like it at the time.
And I was really concerned
that I need to have
a bowel movement while we're
going to have a bowel surface in.
And I got through that period
and figured, well,
we got it made.
We could get back
to the manifold and use them back
and I still couldn't.
It was the late day
and that was the one for it.
Did you ever get any clamps
or anything like that?
No, no, no.
I got no service at all.
I wasn't uncomfortable.
I didn't even have a feeling of fullness.
I'm not you out.
How's your cycle now?
I had one and a half bags.
On the third day
of people.
And another bag on above the
seventh day.
I'm sorry.
No problem.
There are normal
consistent seams for this part.
That's really excellent.
I agree with you.
We've identified it better.
There are a whole hygiene thing
and this thing is so
our daily design believer one.
We just got to do better
than that if we're going to keep people in space.
It feels civilized.
Yeah.
The whole man's
as a vegan.
And the ability to clean up
afterwards,
in fact,
the ability to maintain personal hygiene
throughout the flight is only
we need better.
Student, how about you?
I went to 80 hours.
It was the first one.
I remember to stick it
because I said between 80 and 81 hours
approaching LOI while I'm going to do it.
Which pleasantly surprised me too.
We're on the gory subject
because pre-flight I anticipated
that I might have to use
the bag more than that
because in my normal course of events
it's very common for me
to hit the head at least twice a day.
And so I was pleasantly surprised
that I got 80 hours.
And then I had one other one
and it was after T.E.I.
I guess the next day after T.E.I.
I don't remember what time frame
it was.
Yeah, I guess it was.
It was the day after T.E.I.
And I don't remember the T.E.
I can't even associate with
anything.
I don't know what else is going on at that time.
Yeah.
I remember you guys.
Okay.
When did you first start to use
the nose drums?
How far into the
Do you remember what things?
Third day wasn't it?
Third day.
And do you feel it?
That was a...
I'm a little bit confused about your
your describing as fullness.
And still...
You feel like this was a thing that was
associated with this fullness
that was due to the weightlessness
or do you think it was an oxygen effect?
Just due to the drying and so forth.
I never felt that dry.
And at the time I thought it could have been
either or both.
And so I just treated it simply mathematically
with a couple of...
About one drop in each mouse
was completely infected for the next 10, 12 hours.
Well, you could hear it.
This is a fairly routine.
You hear this in the guy's voices
and you know, they're doing it.
You know, you hear this full feeling that they have.
Sometimes a little bit of horse
sensation with it too.
And it comes and goes.
And you described it on top very well yesterday.
You know, sometimes in the mornings it would be.
You wake up and be better in the morning.
You know what?
I guess this is kind of a subjective feeling.
It's kind of felt that maybe the whole
hand sensation was related to a rate
doesn't be a little cardiovascular system
and therefore...
It is.
If you could relax a little bit and easily
and help it, this is like...
I mean, you could kind of wish it that way.
It's just a general feeling.
I think it was substantial.
I think I've heard of those drops of things.
It didn't help the overall full sensation.
Did it work all right?
I know we got a special wisp do here,
but did they work all right?
Just what prompted that?
Well, I said it clear up.
It made it clear it clear up.
It used temporarily a few hours.
Yeah.
Okay.
And we still want about now,
did you just give yourself to make a song?
Does that what happened to it?
I think I probably did, Chuck.
I'm sure that's what happened.
I said, well, I hadn't used any up to land,
but on entry, you know,
and then, well, I think I'll just use some of these beauties.
And I think I hit maybe too big of a dose
in the right nostril here,
because for my high-starred water,
and I could feel it in my sinuses and everything else.
But it lasted maybe an hour.
And by the time...
I probably did that a couple of three hours prior to entry
and an hour later, you know,
I think most of the symptoms have gone away
that are you getting closer to entry
and you stop worrying about it.
But, yeah, I did.
I think I overdid it.
And I just, you know,
I hardly ever take any nose drop for anything
and maybe I just get too much in there
and it's probably pretty powerful stuff.
It is powerful.
I know if I did one G or here,
if I take more than a couple of drops of that,
or if I used drop them to the spray,
I'd get the same effect.
Yeah, that's not it.
There's a burden in a real garage.
And it wasn't a lack of briefing or not trying it
before flight or anything like that.
I think I'd just let low-presellance in the application.
Well, you know, two drops of good, two or four.
Yeah, you know, what the hell?
Did you feel it?
You got any...
Did you get a tachycardia with that?
Did you get any real increase in hiring with that?
Oh, I had a focus on it.
You didn't feel it anymore.
Yeah.
You had to go ahead and do it.
Thumbs up.
It worked.
You got mad at us for suggesting to me
what we used to go.
Yeah, I would state off at the suggestion.
That's a good thing.
You all had some evidence in your ears on the first exam
when Bill saw you having some bubbles in there.
And did you have any sensation during the reentry
that you were having trouble clearing your ears any of you?
No, it's not surprising to me.
I was looking forward to surprising with him.
I have no problem.
No, I've been.
I could feel a pressure change.
Yeah.
But, you know, I could hear him pop.
But, you know, I could do...
I did that too on my suit integrity change.
I could feel a pressure.
Yeah.
And you know, and you just sort of pop it.
That might come in for a forget about this voice,
sounding full.
You know, I noticed that you'll do that a lot
if you...
I think maybe it's because of the atmosphere is dry,
but if you're doing a lot of talking,
and then you come on and I would know it's myself
sounding full and I'd say, gee, I'm sounding like that.
And my head wasn't constantly full at all.
But I could tell in my voice that I was sounding.
You're in it, you're born.
If you've been doing a lot of talking.
Right.
Well, that's true.
If you do, you know, if you didn't have just talking
on that, like, if you end up here, I could have said,
yes, forget where you talk to rocker,
maybe you might even have that.
That kind of thing, if you just talk to rocker
in a day, you can have it.
Well, I don't have too much else to do with your girls.
Yeah.
You're back with that.
Hey, Chuck.
Come in on those.
Yeah.
We're looking for somebody to kind of go at.
Who is it?
Yeah.
Come in on the African bottle.
The pressure gets to them.
They separate into the gillion bubbles.
Not a boss of this very bubbly filled with air.
So it's a big cap off.
It comes out.
It starts leaking.
It's a knowledge.
It's like, yeah.
Okay.
And it's kind of difficult to control that stuff.
Yeah.
That was the first time you open the bottle.
Always.
Every time you open.
What technique did you use for finding those drops?
How did you put it in?
Very gentle squeeze.
Try to get just one drop or time out.
Just put the drop up.
Put it in there and hose this.
Just like we told it to.
Yeah.
Good boy, man.
Good boy.
Did you take those PRDs down in your suits?
Tae-foop.
You'll never believe it, Charles.
We have zipper pockets.
You're kidding, huh?
It's unbelievable.
They went right there. We pulled out those coveralls and they were zippers on them.
First time we'd seen zippers, no old trade cycle.
So they're none of the training suits. They're just on display.
Well, how about that?
Okay.
We had requested way, way back and forgotten about them.
We made the official request and it was already in the mail.
Another trade device for that way will be all out of the package they gave with them.
Oh, that's a great.
Those were great too.
Okay.
Well, I don't understand what that is.
But when you remove your PGA now, is there a point of the checklist where we should include the little of the PRDs back into your flight coveralls?
Or is that not there?
It's already says take all the items out of here.
Oh, it does.
So that happens to be one that's by itself.
I see.
If you forget that extra pockets there, you're good.
Well, now it's listed in there when we take the suits off the first day.
I guess, you know, and then when you bring the suits back over from the lay-on wide, you know, pretty rush timeline,
that you wouldn't, I don't know, it was being good to put that in your timeline book or not,
because that time your main purpose is to just get the suits and get them stowed.
You said you jerk them down and kind of zipped up in those banks pretty fast.
Right into that, right in the back.
Okay.
Probably wouldn't have heard, I guess, when we list the items to take out of the suits.
When we come back to the land, we just had PRDs in there as another item.
There's sunglasses and pencils and all sorts of them.
That's what it is.
And then on the item, sunglasses.
Now, when did you, when you said you use sunglasses, you don't know what you did use some sunglasses?
Is that right?
No.
Oh, okay.
When did you use the correct one?
Couples.
I don't have a great small frame of them.
It was quite worth it.
And just in the command module field.
Yeah.
Well, they held up all the time.
I didn't use them.
No.
I didn't.
I didn't use them.
Yeah.
Did you have any, did you have any feeling about that on a lunar surface?
No.
That the light levels were finally completed because of that.
Because that is a very typical thing.
That's an interesting point.
The light levels would be higher in the lunar module.
The thing that you don't simulate on the LMS is the difference between the night on the
side of the moon.
How about LMS versus dark all the time for all the back of the cases?
How about out on the surface when you were actually out on the surface and had your
visor down?
Yeah.
That was my plan.
That was my, you know, I mean, did you feel that you were having any, any different
movies?
Okay.
Did you have bombs I had?
It was my reading small print.
It was close.
Yes, it was in the light level.
Yeah.
And I had the property LMS a couple of times when you see a mess in the other.
I think I don't know how many times I wrote them up.
I don't know perhaps.
Yeah.
It was a great time for the time.
Which I've read in a damn card.
It's the best only time I've ever seen you do something like that.
All the surface chugging to either start quite, I mean, dazzling white or it's absolutely
black or something.
I don't think I said that's a great deal of it.
Yeah.
That's right.
I think you've covered most of that stuff about the vision on the surface and sort of
pretty well in there.
I think you've done that very well in the, in the face around it.
We need it.
If we have something that comes back up for that, we'll give the work to you.
But as far as I can tell from getting through our right so far, I think we got most of
that covered.
I just want to point out to you if you want to pursue the visibility further for any sort
of medical things.
If you look at the photographs, it might have been in there exactly what we saw.
Is that right?
If you look cross-side, the visibility is great.
If you look up-side, everything's layered out by the sun.
If you look down-side, all of the gentle, subtle rolling and some dude craters, they just
disappear on it.
Yeah.
But cross-side visibility is great.
The photographs are at the same way.
It's kind of hard to tell when you're looking at just negative to the 70 millimeters,
but I was looking at some of the zero-phase pictures last night and how the targets would
disappear at zero-phase.
It does it on the films.
Also, as it turned out, I'll have to see what the prints look like.
But my first impression is that I didn't see much more than what the camera did at zero-phase,
which is going to surprise me because I would have thought different.
Yeah.
But I don't take that as any sort of data until I've had a chance to really see a blown-up
print.
I'm just looking at some negatives in here.
But that's my first impression.
We've always said that the eyeball can see more than the film can, but with our particular
film, they're a pretty good correspondent.
No, you're going to be about the same.
That's great.
Yeah.
I didn't see you anyway.
We have a bad eyeball.
No.
What is that?
Good film.
That's a pretty great film.
Hey, on the sunglasses, I guess you got it.
This part's on.
I don't know if nobody even broke the sunglasses out.
Right.
And you didn't feel you needed them?
No.
Right.
Well, I think the only time we needed them was when there was sun-shafting in, but in PDC,
it just weighed a couple of minutes.
It could be gone.
It goes away.
Okay.
And there was a time in 196 hours where we lost your respiratory situation, your CPN.
Did you notice whether it was the signal conditioner disconnected there?
Was there a sensor?
It was right.
No.
There was nothing different.
It just went.
You couldn't see anything obvious as the line.
No.
I went down, went over the whole system, checked the sensors, checked the belt, checked the
connection.
And we were getting too close to entry to really do a great deal of troubleshooting.
There was no point to do it.
Okay.
Fine.
But we're going to check those in.
We never had a signal conditioner as such fail.
And that's one of the things that's sort of interesting to do.
It's the one to sensor problem.
We want to be sure to check those signal conditioners out.
Okay.
I think we got most of this mobility thing done in there.
I was talking about the environment, Bill.
Let me just say, I think my urine bite from the CTA problem is kind of related to that
belt in that, you know, the UCTA's held by that plastic strap.
Right.
I think the problem in getting that hose length correct has to do with the fact that
the UCT doesn't always end up in the same place.
You try to get it below the belt so that it doesn't get on top of it or increase the
information in whether you're already done.
And I think in doing that, I probably will work more.
You know, will again not have it for me.
Yeah.
I mean, I think it's the same way that I think it would be fixed.
I think it's the same way that I think it would be fixed.
Yep.
And then it wouldn't move up and down.
And therefore, you can adjust the hose length.
Oh, better.
I mean, I wore mine differently.
I wore mine over the mine belt.
That might be the deal.
Well, I think it's a question of fixing the vertical height of the thing.
So you can get the right length of the hose.
And I think when you reached in, you probably thought it was, you know, saying now
it's without being full of fluid in one hand, but also, because I used to work below
or use the belt on the other hand.
But I guess I always had a definite kink in it.
It came out of the fitting.
It just made a sharp kink, and it was bent.
It was stuck.
It's kink, just like you said.
It went in.
Very good.
Did you feel any real dryness of skin as such?
Or is it dryness of your lips or your nose at all?
Did you ever have any sensation that way?
Not exceptionally for me.
I should have had any obvious sensation for you.
I don't know if the student bed.
I noticed his lips were cracking about 4 to 5 day up.
We got a lot of kitty eyes.
But I don't know what we've got about it.
No.
I didn't feel dry.
In fact, I know it's cracking in here, too.
But no.
I didn't feel any dryness, particularly at all.
OK.
I think we got these alternatives.
Did they talk to you about the field champ?
I wanted to tap on the light flesh thing on the end of this thing.
Yeah.
I did it out here.
Why don't you tell me to come on in and let him get that out of the way.
Hey, Chad, just real fast.
I know you've got to take the data and you're looking ahead to the longer flights.
I'm not trying to downplay it.
But this weight loss, you know, I think in my case, I don't want to be misconstrued.
I was just sitting there thinking, you know, I weighed less after I feel thrifted to Iceland
than I did after this flight, too.
A weight loss of me of five pounds is no just, you know, comes and goes with no problem at all.
Well, that's why the body water things are going to be pretty important.
Yeah, no.
You know, is that really it, you know, is it really a total body water loss?
I don't think that'll be a real important front thing on you.
That's why we'll go over there with you.
So it is clear.
We don't have a total body water or something or an exercise or food space.
It's like 14.
Now we've done a baby.
Those are data matters.
We're just doing the downtown here.
Why can't we get it out?
I don't want to lie to you that way.
Or you're stuck.
We're just stuck.
I'm quick.
Let's get it out.
I'll talk with you later.
There's a scientist.
Let's go.
Yeah, there he is.
They don't go out.
If you don't want any coffee, I've got a big pot right here.
Yeah, I'm coming over to get some right now.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, man.
I think it's just that we should tack on a few questions about light questions.
The end is briefing.
That's what we're about to do.
What we'd like to do is to clarify some of the subjective impressions that you've got.
What you saw on the way of light flashes, and also to clarify the conditions I know
what you saw.
Excuse me.
Can you stand back from the mic just a little bit?
That's a cool mic.
I can't just sit right here.
He'll pick it up.
Okay.
I'm really glad I was out.
All right.
Let's go.
You need to get really close to the mic.
Okay.
You feel the right for the mic?
Is there a way to improve?
Because you got it.
Is that the room to be there?
Yeah.
All right.
You're going to walk.
The first question we got is the streaks that you saw with a very sharp phenomenon or with
a rather diffuse, like fuzzy.
Once I saw a very sharp, so there was no mistake in what it was, it was a streak.
Still long.
I guess the pennies we could have heard.
Yeah.
I think that's correct.
Both the single streak and the double shot could be very clear to me.
They were quite clear.
And I think I made the comment over the look that most of my streaks appeared to be on the
periphery.
And for the first several days, I got the impression that this direction was predominant.
Later on, it appeared that I don't think I could get that good of pattern.
But that was my first impression for the first couple of days.
The next question is, was there any apparent direction of propagation?
And could you tell it was coming from one side to the other or was it just a flash?
Some of the times we didn't say from the left of the right or something like that.
I tried to correlate it, but in my case, I couldn't really correlate a pattern on it.
Yeah, I would think that the time period, which we tried to report the streak by streak
flashed by flash was represented.
And it was my feeling that it was generally random during that time period.
And therefore, generally random throughout the time that we were noticing.
Now, I meant, could you detect that it was moving from one side to the other or general?
It was moving in a specific...
A specific flash?
A specific flash, yes.
Yes.
But you could see it as a travel from one side?
You really could have tried to report that way.
Yes.
You would have to report that way.
Because it happens to me.
It has to be very fast, you know.
And that question kind of redundant, then.
I believe you.
Was there some character to these flashes that had some aspect of direction?
Were they all the same rod shaped or were they...
Do they have a tail on them?
Well, what I reported as a streak was simply that.
Now, maybe the way we determined the direction subconsciously was that it was a ball of light
moving in a direction, leaving a tail.
But I can't say that for sure.
All I reported was a streak, and I had the impression of the moving from one direction
to the other.
And I reported that direction, and I can't clarify my point on that.
Do you want to...
I mean, maybe while you're asking a question, we just don't specialize.
I think they can see this in the dark room.
But just right.
If the idea is to try to see whether this is what you saw or similar to it,
I think you need to like that.
Can you see anything?
Yeah.
That's what it looked like, except it was traveling.
In other words, it started out and it definitely progressed across the field of view.
The direction of motion for individual.
Was it that right?
Yeah, except you're not traveling.
It was traveling.
You thought it was...
It's a point of an easy speech.
I never had to see two simultaneously either.
You have two streaks right now.
I never saw that.
All right.
At one time, you said you saw a semicolon two things.
So what?
A semicolon...